you know the phrase keep your friends
close but your enemies closer well Joe
Biden appears to be doing just that the
Wall Street Journal reporting that China
is negotiating with Cuba to establish a
new joint military training facility on
the island
could be wrong with that that means that
Chinese troops could end up being just
100 miles off the coast of Florida
Secretary of State Anthony blinken
doesn't seem too worried about it though
because
he's been clear
made very clear that we would have deep
concerns about
PRC intelligence or military activities
in Cuba we've engaged in a number of
diplomatic efforts
in that regard and I think they've had
some success this is something we're
going to be monitoring very very closely
and we've been very clear about that oh
monitoring really
now this from the guy who just assured
president XI jinpin that we wouldn't get
in their way of taking Taiwan
even if we try the CCP knows the bind
Administration is limited and what they
would actually do is the New York Times
rights clashes over issues between China
and the U.S have become much more acute
over recent years as China's military
and economic power have grown and Aegean
is aides perceive the United States to
be in terminal decline
gee I wonder why
joining me now Florida Congressman Mike
walls Congressman I think this is the
biggest news uh in the United States
facing our country right now is what's
happening in Cuba and our absolute
indifference
to this happening no red line no don't
even think about it just we're going to
be monitoring it right your reaction to
this tonight
Laura let's let's let this sink in just
for a moment because you're right this
is a seminal historic moment we are on
the verge of having Chinese Communist
Party troops in the Caribbean a hundred
miles from the southern coast of Florida
I mean it's like taking me back to the
1980s the movie Red Dawn where you had
Soviets and Cubans and you know invading
the United States they're taking a play
right out the Soviet Playbook but Laura
this is a world right now where our
enemies our adversaries do not fear any
consequences they harass our planes
harass our ships break into our bases uh
spy on our nuclear facilities uh with a
sophisticated balloon not a silly
balloon and now put troops in our back
door and they get rewarded with a
meeting it's it's truly astounding it's
dangerous and this is how Wars start and
if you contrast that to just a few years
ago so with Trump what happened there
Iran hits our Embassy and kills an
American suleimani their field General
dead right Isis gets out of control
continues to attack uh us and Europe
baghdadi dead the Russians cross a red
line in Syria 300 Russian Wagner
mercenaries dead and restorance is in in
deterrence was restored that's how you
keep the peace that's how you prevent
Wars but you have a bunch of academics
uh right now light blinking like Austin
and others that think if I can just get
them to the table if I can just be nice
enough I can just make enough
concessions then they'll be kind back
and it just we it could not be more
dangerous do you believe
um which is this is what I believe that
the Elites in Washington and Academia in
Wall Street
they they've actually already come to
terms of the fact that China has
eclipsed the United States and they just
want to smooth things out now I call it
a surrender because I think it is and I
I work for President Reagan as a young
person in my early 20s okay I think it's
a surrender how would you describe this
well it's it's it's a quiet surrender
with everybody making money on top of it
Laura all the establishment institutions
that the Democrats care the most about
Academia Hollywood Sports industry woke
corporations on Wall Street number one
they believe America is fundamentally a
Bad Country uh number two they have
Marxist uh roots in the sense of what's
going on with you know with she pushing
socialism with Chinese characteristics
and number three they can just keep the
status quo we can make make the next
bonus make the next next quarterly
earnings so Biden blanken and crew Don't
Rock the Boat keep the drave the gravy
train uh coming and House Republicans
are doing everything we can to stop it
we're going to ban Farmland purchases
we're going to ban I have a bill that
we're introducing tomorrow to ban
pensions from the military pensions from
investing in into Beijing yeah build up
our military armor allies this is how we
event uh This World War III that's right
around the corner uh from starting I
will I will add build our industrial
base back better that's what we need to
do Congressman wonderful bring the
supply chains home we have to bring this
up we have to bring home absolutely
Congressman thank you so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else